it's not just science fiction powerful
machines and algorithms are already
capable of diagnosing illnesses
performing surgery and driving
autonomous cars these technologies
provide us with new tools and disrupt
the way we work yet no one can tell what
impact artificial intelligence will have
on society I think that we need to have
ethical and fundamental rights impact
assessment how the functioning of
artificial intelligence will influence
on many issues which are important for
our everyday life we have invested a lot
of hope in these new technologies
especially for health care and decision
making processes but artificial
intelligence also raises ethical and
legal questions for instance could the
development of new AI applications be a
threat to human rights should
individuals have to go through facial
recognition or effect recognition when
an AI can recognize or predict your
emotional state in a job interview so I
would agree that right now we need to do
more of the work of understanding what
is going on before we create regulation
and policy this means we can set global
standards also for artificial
intelligence to make sure there are some
ethical rules that everybody would
follow to accept that we will not use AI
weaponized AI and against humanity it
will be to complement and not to replace
humans we will not develop consciousness
these questions were at the centre of a
recent meeting of experts in Brussels
organized by the European Parliament
panel for the future of science and
technology stoah the gathering shed
light on proven cases of human rights
violations by AI and highlighted
potential responses to risks for example
ethics frameworks regulatory oversight
and legal safeguards could help us to
avoid the misuse of artificial
intelligence
you